JENNY BROWN: So
far, we've learned
that Critter
Junction has decided
to go with Cloud Run
for their layout app.
Will they learn to optimize
Cloud Run for scalability?
Stay tuned.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
To refresh, the layout app
is a key part of the game.
You can share house
layouts with other players.
And since containerizing
their Node.js application,
they've decided
to run it on Cloud
Run for its portability,
statelessness,
and auto-scaling, even to zero.
And unlike their online
site running on App Engine,
they haven't needed to write
warm up wrappers in their code,
because Cloud Run may keep
some idle instances around
to handle spikes in traffic.
The thing is, Cloud Run will
terminate unused Cloud Run
containers after some
time, which means
a cold start can still occur.
After looking at recent
deployments of the layout app,
we noticed a few things
that could be improved
to minimize cold start latency.
First, they happened to be
using a dynamic language
with dependent libraries, like
importing modules and Node.js.
They weren't using
global variables,
and their container-based
images were
about 700 megabytes in size.
This meant that overall, they
were facing longer load times
upon container startup or
required additional computation
before the server could
start listening for requests.
Instead, they want to
optimize their service startup
speed to minimize the
latency that causes these.
Let's dive into each.
For starters, on Cloud Run, the
size of your container image
does not affect cold start
or request processing time.
But you want to be careful
when it comes to applications
written in dynamic languages.
For example, if you're
using Node.js or Python,
module loading that happens
on processed startup
will add latency
during a cold start.
Also, be aware of some modules
that run initialization code
upon importing.
To build a leaner
service, you can
minimize the number and
size of dependencies
if you're using a dynamic
language, instead of computing
things upon startup,
compute them lazily,
shorten your initializations
and speed up time
to start your HTTP server, and
use code loading optimizations
like PHP's Composer
auto-loader optimization.
Next up, global variables.
In Cloud Run, you can't
assume that service state
is preserved between requests.
But Cloud Run does reuse
individual container instances
to serve ongoing traffic.
That means you can
declare a global variable,
so when new containers are spun
up, it can reuse its value.
You can also cache
objects in memory.
Moving this from the storage
request logic to global scope
means better performance.
A lot of this boils down to
creating a leaner service.
You want to build
a minimal container
by working off of a lean base
image like Alpine, Distroless,
or Scratch.
These images reduced Critter
Junction's image size
from 700 megabytes
to 65 megabytes.
They also made sure to only
install what was strictly
needed inside the image.
In other words, don't
install extra packages
that you don't need.
Once Critter Junction was able
to remove dependencies, use
global variables, swap
to a leaner base image,
and remove extra
packages, they were
able to reduce the latency
of any Cloud Run cold starts.
Now, there are
other best practices
for Cloud Run scalability
and performance,
so be sure to check
out the link below.
Stay tuned.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]